[Music]
my name is matty van truyon
and we are in feral scotland
i'm a crafter and a knitter
i design feral garments and i sell them
online
[Music]
[Applause]
fedele is known
in the world as a knitting technique
that involves stranded collar knitting
so it's basically carrying two colors
together in one row sometimes three
it's called fair isle because originated
here in the island
the shetland wool was known for being
one of the softest wolves in the world
fair isle belongs to the shetland
islands
the population of ship is a lot higher
than the human population
[Music]
the making of a feral jumper i think it
can be divided in two different
processes one is the husbandry of the
animals and then the other one is the
making of the garment
you have a flock of sheep looking after
them feeding them make sure that they
stay healthy so that you produce a good
fleece
[Music]
shearing i found that the best way to do
it is by allowing the ship to rest on
your legs
they become very dose island kind of
happy animals
the moment that becomes like a factory
thing then the relationship changes
completely
[Music]
the fleece is spread out you clean any
debris any grass you roll it in one
little bundle
then it's sent out to jameson spinning
in mainland shetland with the good
shepherd
they're sorted and they're graded
according to the quality of the wool
then they get processed
it gets washed it gets sort of pulled
apart dyed spun
twisted and then we get the cones
[Music]
the cones get sent normally with the
aeroplane from tin wool into fetal
i received my yarn with the plane i got
collected and bring it to my studio and
then the process of making the garment
begins
it comes the design stage i start
putting together colors and patterns and
i create swatches
once the design is approved then we go
into the detailing
the knitting process starts with
producing the ribs taking that drip
transferring it into the flatbed
knitting machine
i place all my wools and then i start
knitting the garment
the machine reads the solid and hollow
front back right sleeve left sleeve
all these panels get put together
the sleeve gets attached by a technical
grafting creates an invisible thing
the seam gets sewn along the sleeve
[Music]
i produce the neck and then the neck
gets grafted into the garment
once the garment is nature is the
finishing process
trimming all the insides you have to
weave in the ends it's the moment where
i can check if there's been any mistake
on the weavings
the garment gets washed in 30 degrees
temperature
put it on the stretcher in the woolly
horse to dry
[Music]
once it's dry it gets pressed unlabeled
it's normally wrapped in brown paper
parcel kind of old style with a little
string of wood
the knitting belongs to the island
people stop doing it they leave the
island and someone else comes and
carries on so feeling that i'm
continuing a tradition and preserving a
heritage is full of satisfaction
[Music]
you